I'm Kevin Kelly with the long now
foundation and so not only did Stewart
volunteer to take care of diamonds place
at the last minute but he had the great
misfortune of having his laptop stolen
last night after he had worked on all
week blitz to develop this talk which by
the way is the first time he's ever
talked on this it's so it's a brand new
topic
brand-new speech and a long gone slide
show which he recreated this afternoon
okay so if he's a little bit
so yeah so so be nice to him I'm sure
this was not exactly as it was last
night in his practice run but I'm sure
also that'll be amazing and it's about
the city planet a long-term trend
happening on the planet little notice by
anybody and a part of the long-term view
I won't introduce Stuart because he's
the host of this series and as I
practice we tend not to do introductions
because they're easily found on your
card you have the long list of his
cultural innovations through time but he
is always interesting and I'm sure will
amaze us again with a new view so here's
Stuart
this could be you I keep finding their
news and it's news that I'm not seeing
anywhere else you find it hidden down
and UN population reports and and a
little-known books like one that Paul
Hawken gave me on the slums of the world
which is excellent it's really the best
book in that stack and it fit was some
of the thinking that's been going on
around long now for a while in ways that
may be different than what the UN and
and others are thinking about it in
so you'll see connections with other
talks here with Phil long ones from
several months ago from Rob north in
June really from all of them because
there's a there's something deep going
on this will give you an indication all
right we're gonna do a work around here
and yeah I've seen this enough times I
think I can actually do the sound
alright here we are four three two one
fire fire
Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam Bam ladies and gentlemen
you've just witnessed history yeah well
that's the history of cities
and that's what they do that's what
they're especially used they even in
Europe European cities change their
fabric two to three percent of Europe
which means they completely change over
their physical makeup about every 50
years and that's the slowest part of the
world here in the u.s. our cities
turnover faster in the developing world
they turnover faster and so even ancient
cities they look like their cities on a
hill they're actually cities made that
made the hill
these are tells this one happens to be
tell burr Sheba and Israel and you can
always tell where a city was in the
Mideast is you look around for round for
a flat top hill it's made of the old
buildings that fell down gradually of
debris garbage poop skeletons and that's
what cities do is they grow up on top of
their own past even in a place like
Boston this is a page from how building
has learned between 1860 and 1981 none
of the buildings in the first photograph
are in the second photograph except for
the Old South Church which is still
there was kept for historical reasons
some of the early Revolutionary War
stuff happened there but what's also
interesting is is you see some of the
streets are still the same Washington
down here Franklin up there and while
the fabric changes something doesn't
cities have patterns they have a
character they have some things that are
extremely durable so one of the reasons
long now is so interested in cities is
they well are some of the fastest
changing things that people do most
rapidly changing organizations they're
also the oldest they're cities like
Jericho that is ten thousand five
hundred years old still occupied back in
the very early days five hundred years
after the farmer set up shop there they
build a tower
I used to have a picture of that was
amazing
ten thousand years ago they built a
tower 30 feet wide the stub is 30 feet
high no one knows how high that the
original was and it had the
sophisticated spiral staircase inside it
and a huge wall Jerico carries on to
this day
places like nearby Jerusalem continues
to be an important city century after
century millennium after millennium and
it's been run by nearly everybody in
that part of the world at one time
another usually after a sacking and so
the city would be destroyed and the
Maccabees would take over and the
Persians would take over and then the
Greeks would take over and the Romans
would take over and some Muslims would
take over and then Christian Crusaders
took over and then the Ottoman Turks got
it and Brits had it for a while Israelis
have it for now this is what happens
with cities they they go through
enormous change but they endure many of
them endure and I think that robustness
that resilience is one of the things
that we can be looking at in the
civilizational terms okay come to the
present moment right now we're at a
crossing point in history where the
world population the rural population
has been this is just going back to 1950
you go all the way back it gets much
stranger has been gradually leveling off
and is now about to start dropping
meanwhile urban population is increasing
enormous Lee at the crossover point is
50 percent right now that's expected to
be in two years 2007 the majority of
people on earth will be urban dwellers
this is somewhat new because not so long
ago 200 years ago it was 3% of humans
lived in cities a hundred years ago
hundred and five years ago it was 14%
lived in cities you can tell something
ferocious is going on when you have a
trend like that moving along and by the
way the the expectation is about 2030
another 25 years from now it'll be 61
percent this is world size now this is
one of the slides that fell long menus
I'm coming back to you because I'm going
to in a sense expanding on it tonight
the developed world past the the
majority point for urban dwellers way
back in 1950 and what you can expect is
that the less developed regions are
coming right along and are going to
basically follow this pattern and so the
whole will increasingly follow the
pattern in developed countries have
already gone through what's coming on
now and what's kind of interesting this
diagram which is one I found today and
added is the sequence of events of the
purple is the growth up to the year 2000
and the red is the party expected from
from now on so Japan and Tokyo
drew a humongous amount it got to about
twenty six point four million and the
expectation is it's going to stay right
there whereas other places especially in
India and in China and in Africa like in
Lagos these places their biggest growth
is yet to come
these are really really big cities I
mean I had a list of the top ten New
York used to be in them and it's barely
and it used to lead the way 50 years ago
now it's barely on the list so I think
we're looking at turns out historically
the numbers are such that this is the
most massive movement if you
in history and one of the numbers is
thrown around is every week a million
new people show up in cities in the
world global business network and I have
been looking at China recently and it's
interesting that the people talking
about China and the Chinese expect 300
million people to move into town that's
a quarter of the present population the
population is still going up rather
slowly so what you're seeing is people
leaving the countryside and moving into
the city so this is some kind of tipping
point we're right at right now it's a
shift of depth that we'll be finding out
for the rest of our lives part of what's
going on is there's structural things
going on with globalization that for
example tend to go right to the cities
go right past the national boundaries
right past the national governments
right to the cities where the action is
the bigger the city is get the more
that's the case in a lot of the
developing countries especially where
these huge cities are some of them the
government has really been discredited
and everybody's figuring out workarounds
to get past them the multinational
corporations go straight to where the
workers and the markets are if they can
and increasingly they can and they do
and that increases the the whole process
likewise NGOs and there are all kinds of
them involved in the cities now go
straight to where the action is they've
stopped giving money to the governments
because it goes to Switzerland instead
they take their people and their money
to the cities where the need actually is
and then that helps the cities and
there's something that is being called
subsidiarity where there's a fashion to
move power down through regions and
governments and that is at least
weakening the state governments and to
some extent increasing power at the
lower level so
I think you can see that there's a real
geometrical and mathematical statistical
difference here which is that nations
are pretty much defined by their
boundaries and more and more of what's
going on is not interested in boundaries
it's interested in centers it's
interested in nodes and cities our
Center as they are nodes and so this is
a way to look at the world that's the
world at night made out of real images
made by the Defense Department actually
an assembled by NASA and you don't see
much national boundaries there what you
see is cities and the avenues between
them this is a connectivity map that's
what cities are about and that's what
the earth looks like at night you could
say that the dark side of the earth is a
star shine down and these days the earth
is shining right back the cities are
shining right back one thing I did pull
off in that today is a poem from Robert
Frost of all people he said this he said
the city is all right to live in the one
is to be civilized stay up and read or
sing and dance all night and see sunrise
by waiting up instead of getting up
so the round goes meanwhile there's
another way to look at the earth this is
just one of many internet Maps oh this
one happens to be of what's called the
core and it's showing the period linking
the pure linkings that go on in this
case between what was this thing it's
doing well
the lower hunk there is North America up
to the left I believe is Asian over to
the right is Europe among other things
that's showing there's a lot of linkage
between North America and Europe North
America and Asia not much between Asia
and Europe yet so functionally North
America is still the core of the
Internet the Europe is coming on strong
Lygia is coming on strong and they have
a wonderful time series of this
particular diagram that that gives you a
sense that this is a fast-changing
view of the world I want to expand a
little further on on what was said a
couple months ago by Phil Longley cities
our population sinks turns eight
historians and demographers
have been noticing this for a while they
always have been population sinks and
what happens is people move into town
and the birthrate goes down to the
replacement level that feel long when
talking about a 2.1 children per woman
and it keeps right on going and so you
see not just the leveling off but a real
dropping one of the issues is clearly it
turns out that when you live in the
countryside kids are real asset more to
help on the farm or to marry off but
once you get in the city they turn into
a liability so you know which would you
rather have a child or a million dollars
and the time to enjoy it
and wonder rotifer I mentioned this to
you Joseph Jamie said that seems like a
really low figure so I'll use another
one of the diagrams that slides that
feel long and he had a year this is the
median projection the UN is doing that
going all the way to nine billion but
about seven point six billion and then
at a birth rate of one point eight five
children per woman stabilizing at that
this is what happens over three hundred
years basically you get back down to the
two point something billion that we had
in 1960 so Humanity is is not only
experienced the doubling of its
population in basically our lifetime
it's the last doubling and so it's those
two events you know the one event was
incredible a lot of us organized a lot
of activity around oh my god where's the
population gonna go but then if it hauls
off and stops also in our lifetime
they're so you know there's more coming
but you'll see that there's only so many
more coming that means that this kind of
a turn is a major turn in how people
think about people how people think
about the earth and each other one of
the elements of this is that during this
period of transition you're gonna get a
whole lot more old people and a whole
lot fewer young people and so Phil's
book is called the empty cradle a number
of countries now are trying like mad to
get their birth rates back up and it
turns out it's just as hard to make
people have more babies as it was to
make them have fewer babies they just do
what they're gonna do and they get into
town and they're you know they got
business to tend to
so you have probably a trend coming
where the cities will be occupied by the
young people that's what's happening in
the developing world
extend its what's happening in the
developed world old people go and retire
in the countryside or just never leave
the countryside and stay there until
they die so you not only have a whole
lot of urban growth you've got a whole
lot of young urban growth and that has
this other element that the expectations
now is there's another two billion
people coming we got six point five
billion now there's as many as another
two billion coming in the next thirty or
so years all of that growth will be in
cities the rural population is at least
level during that time and probably
going down and one of the peculiarities
is we're pointing out is that the people
who are in cities have the lowest birth
rates so you've got a combination of
young people in the cities not having
kids because they're busy being urban
and old people not having kids because
they don't do that anymore all right let
me change the subject a little bit oh
this is a diagram I've been flogging for
a couple of years now even this slide
didn't work had to be resized but it's a
jumped-up version of what I did about
buildings that you can separate any
dynamic thing any robust thing into a
series of layers that work at different
paces and there's fast parts in this
case showing fashion Commerce and
infrastructures or the five-year plan
level of infrastructure and down to
slower things like governance
non-governmental ver pretty quickly that
covered the way governing is done in a
place on down to culture which is quite
slow in nature which has these humongous
lis slow things I mean you can save them
but the tsunami was pretty quick but you
only have tsunamis you know the very
long period of time and developing the
the cultural muscle memory for these
long lag things or for things that creep
up on you like global climate change
that's the sort of thing
is why you get so much power from from
the bottom of these layers one example I
give of why I think this is a good
cross-section of any healthy
civilization from Athenian to maybe ours
is that when you see a nation Empire
like the Soviet Union try to change it
so that basically everything was run at
kind of infrastructure pace five-year
plans and they pretty much looked down
on Commerce threw away fashion threw
away culture and change their government
is way too fast when they started and
not too surprisingly it changed pretty
quickly when it quit and so became a
brittle a brittle civilization
another example here you go to Turkey in
1999 there was an earthquake by the way
does anybody else have a laser pointer
that I could borrow this is weirdly it
came back who knows maybe the sound will
come back what you see here is is
commerce having too much influence on
governance basically tricky had
perfectly good building codes that the
commercial folks could buy off the
building inspectors with bribes and go
ahead and build any old kind of building
and they did and the earthquake came
along and took it down so there was
already a misapplication of between the
paste layers there but another
interesting element is what's this
building still doing up well it's a
mosque from a twelve hundred year old
religion and it apparently knows about
earthquakes and you could say well you
know that's a kind of a neat photograph
but you know what about the mosque down
the street and does that really
illustrate anything so you know you go
to Sumatra last December and
find pictures like this well okay that's
a fluke right oh yeah as you can imagine
I got these from an Islamist site that's
it this is obviously a miracle always
looking out for his own but it does show
that one of the things that you can that
you hope for is that the cultural parts
of your civilization are in tune with
the nature parts those two slow deep
profound things bear relation to each
other and this is one case where you can
see it pretty clearly
so just to dissect that diagram a little
bit when I'm proposing is the fast stuff
like fashion and commerce as AWS
learning things and proposing things and
the slow parts their job is to dispose
what's good and that's a good and to
remember the stuff that's worth
remembering well worth going back to you
when shocks come to the system like a
technology suddenly self accelerating
technology comes into your civilization
what's going to take up the the shock of
that and is probably going to be
fashioned in commerce and then the
dragging ass long behind the governance
and having grave doubts about the whole
thing's a culture
discontinuity is the main event in the
fast parts the way fashion works is by
always making sure that the thing you
cared about last year is now out of
fashion and you need to buy this new
thing by the way you see young people
tend toward the top of this diagram
they are absolutely into fashion and
pretty much like uninterested in
cultural history and older people like
me tend to migrate down toward the
bottom of the diagram we're completely
interested in culture and stuff like the
history of cities and fashion bores us
to death you get constraint and
constancy a game can go on if there's
basically game rules understanding of
what the limits within which you do
various things and that comes from the
slow stuff and the let's try at this
different way the deeper stuff beyond
just proposing things real revolution
comes from the faster parts the main
thing in an accelerating time like what
feels like an accelerating time like
we're experiencing right now is most of
the stuff that you see is about the fast
stuff that's where all the attention is
that's when the newspapers and the
magazines and books but the actual power
and I learned this from ecology is in
the slow things the butterfly does not
drive the forest the trees drive the
forest and the butterflies go along on
the sufferance that is the case with
many of the relationship between these
slow and fast parts of a dynamic system
like civilization
I was asked recently to to do a diagram
on how cities learn how cities deal with
things in the world and I was going to
take the civilization diagram and figure
out the different elements that would
apply to a city and I couldn't find any
any way to parse it out differently so I
wound up using this diagram and came to
the momentous conclusion that actually
the civilization and cities are the same
thing it's it's where the word comes
from historians are constantly saying
the civilization is what
happens in cities and the most of the
history that we describe of civilization
is City stuff cities move to to move
pretty quickly here's a example which
fortunately has no sound I'm happy to
say has no sound you'll recognize the
area this is 80 years of the San
Francisco Bay Area urbanizing and
usually there's sinister music with
videos like this oh look at that cancer
growing on that healthy California coast
I don't know it's to me like the you
know inner California coast had this
healthy fast-moving organism come along
you can flip the sign Det often on
cities over there evil or over there
actually pretty good thank you are going
on in the Bay Area at the end of the
city years and there was the beginning
let me see a little more about how I
think that speed in terms of cities is
not necessarily a bad thing and I've got
to tell a little bit of I'm gonna drop a
name Prince Charles asked me to come do
the princes foundation in London a
couple months ago not personally but he
was there and we talked and he said nice
things about me and I said nice things
about him or at least about his you know
the monarchy which does help Britain
think long term I explained them that we
don't have a monarchy so we're building
a ten thousand year clock instead
but the subject of that particular
meeting was theirs
I guess gonna be 800,000 new homes being
built all of a sudden in the Southeast
of England between the Thames and the
Chunnel and because they got the housing
problems there and they want to solve it
kind of all in one go and they expect a
lot of that housing if not most of it to
be manufactured housing
England is held back for manufactured
housing Sweden in Germany and various
other European places have gone ahead
and and manufactured housing like mad
and like it so the princess foundation
was had a great big meeting long day
long meeting on how do you preserve
local identity in of instantly
manufactured set of new towns and three
or four of the speakers before that
everybody was there the minister of
housing and you know the Prince of Wales
comes other people show up yeah I did
and so the number of the people before
me that spoke use this very photograph
if you find it on the net and it's
Levittown in Pennsylvania in the late
1940s and basically all these somewhat
stylistically inclined speakers were
saying this is what we don't need in
England that this is how bad
manufactured tract housing can be so I
went on after a few these folks and I
got up in there and I started my
presentation of this slide and said I
want to show you a little more about
Levittown if you go and look at the old
photographs and they do have some before
and after photographs it's pretty
interesting the changes that have
occurred between nineteen fifty and
fifty years later in 2000 well basically
what happened is I learned this from
pure Schwartz when you go to Levittown
now it looks like just another pence
in your neighborhood well this local
identity it was in no way suppressed in
fact it it seemed to have happened
pretty straightforwardly
and here's why so here you see one of
the you know six or seven different
models he could get eleven thousand six
hundred dollars of your GI bill money
would get you a place with a yard and
lots of neighbors from your generation
where you then created the baby room and
there are a number of things about these
they were built about one a day it
really was manufactured housing that was
site built for example they they
developed slab on grade these places
didn't have basements and the second
floor was left unfinished the idea was
that the owners would do whatever they
wanted with the second floor making an
addict or rumpus room or more bedrooms
for the kids as they came on and a whole
secondary industry developed around the
Levittown's of coming and helping you
figure out what to do with your second
floor and so over time these things all
became quite various a little more web
searching turned up a number of sites
about Levittown and there are no longer
critical sites about Levittown all of
the sites about Levittown or nostalgic
and you find things in any other you can
get mementos from them and people
reminiscing and having all these
discussion groups and so on remembering
growing up in Levittown's and they're
collecting the old magazines that used
to go out to everybody in one of these
houses called thousand lanes and you
could hear the blood draw fall out of
the heads all englishman a thousand
lanes
contradiction into something but among
the things that are in the thousand
lanes magazines is helpful hints for
maintaining and improving your Levittown
homes so what I propose to the princes
foundation is that when you see user
groups like this developing around
something and Alexander Rose pointed out
when he heard this last night this is a
case where ubiquity creates community
when everybody is having the same
experience they can share car parts in a
sense and so there's a community event
that went on with all these people
having the same homes but the contrast
comes with gated communities and typical
and gated communities is they have their
famous CCR's covenants conditions and
restrictions that have details like all
drapes curtains window coverings
shutters or blinds visible from the
street or common areas shall be beige
white or off-white take your pick
there'll be no outside laundering or
drying the clothes and on and on and
this is the norm with a lot of these
communities that are run by the
Neighborhood Association of the owners
associations what's going on is that
these places are being treated primarily
as real estate and so everything has to
do with keeping the real estate value up
and if you can hang laundry out in your
back yard where people can see it that's
going to take the really estate value of
your neighbors down and they don't want
you to and the power that goes to some
of these communities is such they can
take away your home if you violate those
restrictions by contrast you go to a
street in Portland ordinary house this
is exactly the kind of thing which gated
communities are designed to prevent
so my point to the princes foundation I
didn't make it as well then as I should
have but it became clear to me is look
it doesn't matter what the style and the
fabric of the homes you build is if
they're treated as speculative real
estate local identity will not happen if
they're treated as homes and people are
primarily living in them and there's
some continuity that is coming then
local identity will happen whether you
want it to or not and it really comes
down to not something that architects do
as to what kind of building they have or
what kind of style it is it's much more
how does the actual design of the real
estate deals work you'll see more of
this when we get to some of the squatter
cities now another issue that came up of
course at this meeting was the whole
question of manufactured homes so it
turns out then at Toyota this
manufacturing homes and since there are
no manufactured homes companies and
England to the supply said one should go
straight to the top you got a great
corporation and Toyota bring them here
and let them build your 8,000 homes
they'll do a hell of a job and but then
the question is of course you know a
mass-produced product like that can
people actually take something so hard
in mass and remote and global and all
this stuff and turn it into something
really personal and the answer is yes
I love showing this slide to the English
and they love seeing it meanwhile out in
the countryside the very places
countries where these trucks are
happening what's happening out on the
landscape here's a place in Africa
here's a place thank that once in
Bolivia sequence got scram so don't
remember the names that ones in Syria
these are empty villages that ones in
Russia when the Russian and Soviet
economy and world collapsed they stopped
subsidizing a lot of the rural living
and people left as soon as they could
this winds up in the northern islands
that's in South Africa this is in China
and that's a totally empty fishing
village and an island very close to Hong
Kong all over the world I've been asking
travelers and journalists and everybody
who's coming from various parts of the
world are the villages in the
countryside emptying out or you just
were the answer is my gosh how did you
know and it is as near as I can tell
Universal that the world's villages are
just going hollow and fortunately a
couple years ago you know I used to
romanticize about villages like
everybody else's sort of green and I was
at a meeting in Aspen where I heard this
statement made in the village all there
is for a woman is to a bare husband and
family elder pound grain and sing if she
moves to town she can get a job start a
business and get education for her
children her independence goes up and
her religious fundamentalism goes down
that was said by this lady in Kavita Ram
Dass who's near by actually president
the Global Fund for women here's the
dynamic life in the country is dull
back-breaking impoverished restricted
exposed and dangers and I didn't really
understand this until I spent time with
the book that you gave me Paul in slums
they sent serious researchers to serious
squatter cities to find out how the
economy and the people and this stuff
really works and a lot of these folks
yeah scales dropped from their eyes
because they don't ask real questions or
real families are really getting by in
town why are you here it looks like
total squalor look where you live my god
you're on the street people can't bear
to look at your part of town is it's so
congested and filthy and obviously
unhealthy and basically the answer they
got from folks is you should have seen
my village and it turns out that it's
actually quite dangerous especially in
many parts of the world brigands get you
famine gets you disease gets you and
there's no care nearby you work like a
bastard and the weather changes you
don't have crops to sell you're making
it from week to week you have a couple
of bad weeks you're in a bad way and
town it doesn't work like that so the
flip is then the city it's exciting it's
much less grueling kind of work
available it's better paid the freedom
of cities is been an attraction forever
basically you have privacy if you want
it and it is safe it turns out again
from the folks who are going there and
looking as people don't much die on the
streets of these squatter cities they
die out in the countryside they might
say okay that's fine for the development
develop developing world but you know
here in America things are fine right
this happens to be some pictures from
the old Kentucky every state has this
you will find parts of California I'm
sure
Eastern Oregon Eastern Washington the
high plains are getting so empty that
they're being referred to as the Buffalo
Commons and here's the dynamic farm
subsidies are one of many things that
every government is doing to try to keep
people out of the cities and back on the
countryside China is doing it India's
doing that America is doing it and it
turns out there's no farm subsidy high
enough to keep people on the land once
it gets to be a 200-mile mile drive to
school and that's what's happening in
places like South Dakota and Nebraska
and state after state there are towns
there now that are offering free land
for anybody in this room to go and get a
hundred acres with a house all that kind
of stuff just move in please please keep
her town alive and they don't have any
takers so that's the pattern it's
interesting that that the governments
have had so little success trying to
stay this tie to reverse it so here's a
typical place where everybody's going
this one happens to be unreal this is a
plug for Rob Norris Bulacan for his talk
you'll be here month after next and in a
sense I'm sort of preparing the way for
or what he'll be saying he's talking
about he wanted to call his talk the
medieval 21st Century City because these
squatter cities have medieval qualities
they really are like our the European
medieval past and in some ways that's
rough
and in some ways it's pretty interesting
so what are these cities like well okay
here's Mud Pie
and then down here and Nairobi in Africa
Mamba it looks pretty horrible there but
the fact is is Bombay as it used to be
called one-sixth of the gross dimension
the gross domestic product of India is
coming out of Mumbai this is a place
with a whole lot of economic
and all these big cities are and they do
what's happening is the the squatter
cities are vibrant because they're
medieval and since they're organized by
the people who were actually there and
and they build the homes again you know
this is sounding like a libertarian
tirade or something but when the
government's bill architects come and
say all we need is really good housing
and it'll get some money from the
government and I've got this wonderful
design for this really low cost thing
that everybody can live in those then
become the worst part of the slums
inevitably apparently because they're
not built loved and cared for by the
people who are there they're perfectly
capable of building these homes an
interesting thing about it is is they
they do it with family they have family
coming to and from whatever village
they're from they have family they're in
town that's who's getting on their first
jobs that's really going into business
with that's who's getting it together
and sometimes with a bunch of the
neighbors to put up a structure and then
what's especially interesting is where a
whole lot of the real support is coming
from
it's basically religious groups Islam
assists in those cities shivaji called
they call it in Mumbai and Pentecostal
Christians everywhere and they are out
there doing what needs to be done they
are absolutely on the street with the
folks getting jobs taking care of
medical issues connecting up with other
NGOs you can do various kinds of aid and
of getting lots of Converse why wouldn't
they and by their fruits I have to say
they're doing pretty good all of these
squatter cities aren't just sitting
there being poor they have enormous ly
active informed
the economy's going on and we're called
agglomeration economies of these larger
cities make more and more of the
attractions mainly higher wages that
keep people coming to them even though
they're absolutely enormous these things
are surprisingly resilient both the
micro scale and at the macro scale they
got all kinds of problems I don't want
to remain a size these squatter cities
the way we used to romanticize villages
because they'll be just as wrong about
that the fact is people who can vote
with their feet or going into these
places and they're going upstream toward
a job and some money and the the
informal economy is often deeply
interconnected with a formal economy so
you know the hotel is getting some work
done by people who are over in the
favela across town and on and on and on
it's a pretty rich mix what are we
saying so far I'm going to overstate it
because it's part of recalibrating
you're thinking about something what
we've seen is basically the the concert
population problem that you know I
starved for years ago that Paul Ehrlich
said could only come through basically
government programs got taken care of
not by the demographic transition that
very common or another said was going to
happen if only we could get people out
of poverty and get them a certain amount
of money then they'll have fewer kids
not of Education now do you ever get it
then they'll have fewer kids turned out
that wasn't it it's moving to town that
does it and then the other stuff happens
they do get more money they do get more
education but the birth rate goes down
as soon as they're in town so the switch
around has come with a population
explosion is happening the cities you go
to these enormous cities and you see
more poverty than you can possibly
imagine but what you're seeing is people
who have been in poverty for a long time
and are now
one plays busy getting out of it as fast
as they can and inventing all manner of
means of doing it and so the in some
sense the squalor that you see in the in
the slums and the squatter cities would
be horrible if it was stable if the
people weren't moving through it but the
people are moving through it it was
stable but back in the countryside
that's why they left and so to a large
extent some economists are now saying
that basically these cities these mega
cities are curing poverty one thing I
want to end on here is this is a huge
human event what does it have to do with
our relationship to natural systems and
I think there's a green dimension the
one has already been pretty well stated
the idea of the economic footprint that
the cities have a large amount of impact
and an area much larger than they
themselves are and so for example
Toronto is being a lot of attention to
this he has been saying you know the
Greater Toronto Area the GTA could get
its footprint could get this much larger
and this is the kind of stuff that is
making all of these impacts that we need
to keep after and make better but I
think there's more to the story than has
been done with the economic footprint
analysis so far because what I have not
yet seen and all maybe you know
something be someone else here knows was
something but I haven't seen good
comparative analysis between basically a
number of people in the city the effect
they're having on the landscape versus a
number of people in the countryside and
the effect they're having on the
landscape and remember there's a lot of
folks out there and it adds up
furthermore the comparisons can be
peculiar if you have a thousand people
leave a County that has a thousand
people in it and they moved to town that
has a million people the change in that
County is enormous that
in the city is negligible there was an
article in The New Yorker a few years
ago by a guy who had gone off to Vermont
with his wife and they were living the
Carhartt life taking care of things and
he got to noticing that they were
driving all of the time and building all
of the time there's a lot of waste
coming through their process and he
eventually wound up back in New York
saying New York is the greenest city in
the world if you think of it in terms of
of the density and of the per person
fossil fuel use he made an interesting
argument for it
I don't think we really have as much
information about these comparisons as
we need yet so for an environmental
strategy I'd say for a start I don't see
a lot of awareness that this gross
urbanization massive urbanization is
where all the auction action is and also
where a lot of opportunity is for a
couple reasons by the way there's not
much data one factoid I came across was
that in the last five years they've been
thousands of ecological papers I used to
be an ecologist okay and I know what
those papers are made of how many of
them were about urban ecology city
ecology and turns out 0.4% were if this
is where humans are going where the
action is where you want it to be green
I think there's probably more
opportunity for a young ecologist to
become really good at dealing with
cities there's really two kinds of
opportunities going on here one is to
immediately go out to these country
sizes they're emptying out and protect
the hell out of them people will come
back at a certain point and when they
come back gentrifying it or whatever
retired folks going there or whatever
that's when you want to have a lot of
the things already in place so that the
natural systems are in tax of the cycle
of natural fires also the flood plains
all these things are being dealt with in
a
way at the same time if everybody's in
town that's where one should be dealing
and join the Pentecostal Christians in
seeing what needs to be done with folks
right there because that's where they're
changing their lives and their minds and
they can change like many people do and
they live in cities for a while into the
nation's leading environmentalists
that's one of the things that you see in
developed countries that the country
typically is much less green in its
viewpoint people in the city are much
more green and that's a trend that could
be helped and exacerbated what's
imaginable here is a world that has goes
in the direction of seriously green
cities in that seriously green natural
system environment I wanted an image of
that I actually wound up going to Corvis
and buying it not once but twice
this happens to be Queenstown in New
Zealand so that's downtown middle-earth
and as it does show a nice balance of
natural landscape and natural systems in
a city which looks pretty damn
attractive now I have a killer finale
but it involves sound so what I'm gonna
do ya want to see see if that's good
enough or not I've got to work around
but so anyway here we go
I'm gonna give the last word to Brian
you know God willing
it's just
thank you
let's out the lights up a little bit in
the room and also maybe the second spot
over here now that we're not showing
serious pictures anymore
fantastic recovery Stewart so the drill
in case people have not been here before
is if you have questions you write them
on the cards that are easily available
and you give it to someone with the
yellow hat and they'll bring it forward
and we'll go through with them and
select a few of the better ones first
question and also I write your name
because we like to assign credit for
questions and I ask you to stand up or
wave your hand
Rebecca Weiland has a question over
there I what question is what does the
growth of urbanization mean for our
transportation lifestyle of today
hovering would be great that's a really
good kind of technical question and
somebody is an expert on transportation
would wade into the new Urbanists who
you know could give a perfectly
wonderful talk like this would say you
know do more walkable communities
gathered around public transit and a lot
of the things I learned about public
transit is Bart does it exactly wrong it
goes really fast and stops relatively
few times it turns out the best public
transit goes relatively slowly and stops
lots of times because basically every
single stop you see the real-estate
values go up and dense cities clearly
are part of what's being sought here but
an interesting problem this thing of
people in cities not having children has
played out to the point there is an
article in The New York Times about a
week ago of wonderful areas of like
Portland Oregon America's greenest
school the city in some ways on the
Pearl district which is the hip new
place to live in Portland the problem is
you don't want to move there with kids
because they're closing the schools
nearby there's not enough kids to keep
the schools open they're out in the
suburbs and as we go and so on
so what hasn't been figured out yet and
here's a design challenge is how to have
plenty of density in a wave that is
swell for kids they can find each other
they can grow up I think feel safe they
can get around and some of this will be
communication or some of this will be
transportation issues so that's the part
I know about applying to something I
don't know about next question this is
actually kind of a follow-up question
from
Sharyn raise your hand Sharon
brightly-lit Sharon you didn't really
mention suburbs until just now so where
does suburbs fit in are people moving
from rural places to cities are they
going to suburbs do they want city life
or do they want suburban life so are the
suburbs cities are they not are they
something different well you've got the
drill grow should be one of the speakers
and those things actually his next book
will be just about to come out would be
appropriate for it
oh it's is about basically the various
technologies they're transforming about
to transform human nature for the first
time but he did a book called edge
cities a couple years ago that basically
pointed out that suburbs grow up to be
cities and Tyson's Corner around
Washington DC is um one of many we've
had a whole bunch of them here in the
Bay Area
basically you head over the East Bay and
over into the valley there and you're
getting into completely full robust and
happening cities and people that have no
need to go to San Francisco and come
here for talks like this and that's
about it
likewise in Marin County they're talking
about putting the railroad back in
action for a commuter rail and you think
oh boy here comes everybody to their job
in San Francisco actually most of the
traffic on 101 in Marin County is people
going around from one part of Marin
County to another and they'll probably
do the same with the train when it comes
in so what happens is a kind of a
fractal ization in in the suburbs are
probably in some ways the temporary
phenomenon would be wonderful if they
were designed more that way because if
they're designed only like gated
communities with the you know strict
barrier the strict limitations on
anything cool happening and very very
limited transportation capabilities then
those parts will get stuck on other
parts that are more like these squatter
cities where they're kind of
making it up as they go will tend to be
more dynamic even though they're out in
the suburb country and typically it's
these commercial centers which are more
like that that become the edge cities
well it could have been residential
centers if they were more lively by the
way one of the things this literature is
pointing out is that there's various
levels of folks of the live in cities
and there are now a whole kind of people
who live in cities that is they spend
their time going from one city to
another if they have fair amount of
money live homes there pnath there in
each one of those cities and it's not
just one city it's it's the whole set of
cities that they they like to live in so
in more and more in a sense every cities
becoming a world city you used to be you
only had three or four world cities in
the world now you have thousands I have
a question so because you ran out of
good yeah no you didn't show any dead
cities
I mean cities die too you show dead
villages so if the assumption that the
young drive cities was to be false and
we have mostly older people in the
future does that mean there's gonna be a
lot of dead cities the dead cities I'm
aware of this would be a wonderful study
and you go to Angkor Wat you're
obviously seeing a dead City typically
capital cities when a new dynasty comes
along at least in China and says okay
that that's it for this place is the
center of the universe we're gonna have
the sin of the universe over here where
we can build it to my style or
whatever and then the old city tends to
die pretty quickly it's a real good
question I like know more about what it
would take some cities down it you know
there's there's certainly lots of cities
who there's a lot of comparative who's
prospering and who's losing the industry
all of this kind of is making a
conversion to
blue-collar to white-collar a lot of
that kind of analysis is going on but as
far as cities just going stone dead I
guess the closest is Newark New Jersey
Detroit but you know even there I'll bet
there's life in the old girl I bet they
come back one way or another okay here's
a question from Malcolm Dean back away
right there can you relate liberal
versus conservative red state versus
blue state politics to worl versus urban
well I was looking for that when I
looked at this stuff because it was sort
of a theory I went into it all that so
much of the last two elections look like
an urban versus rural center versus
coastal and there's certainly a lot to
it but if the majority of America has
been urban since you know nineteen forty
something clearly that's not a
sufficient explanation because those are
the years that liked it Franklin Delano
Roosevelt and on and on I think there is
and you know pay there's some imbalances
that so that there's more senators per
square voter in rural states than there
are in urban States the Electoral
College is a little behind but it's
trying to keep up I think probably
gerrymandering is as an issue here it
certainly is in Texas and speaking as a
Democrat I we very much in support of
Governor Schwarzenegger urge to put
redistricting out there in a fair way in
this state so that we don't have the
kind of hegemony of Democrats here the
now having a Republicans in the
Washington DC that's my humble opinion
on that matter I think that fair
redistricting will make the
congressional bodies more responsive to
the actual layout of where people are
and what they think the question from
Eric merlic I'm saying it there um do
you think that the advantages of cities
is their ability to learn their ability
to respond quickly and evolve and is
that the differentiating factor from
villages yeah one of the diagrams that I
didn't have time to recreate was taking
that layered diagram of the pace layers
of civilization and say okay that
applies to cities but actually cities
and I took Photoshop and i warped it so
that the fast parts were big in the
nature and culture stuff is a little
smaller to give a sense that cities
specialize in in having all those
relationships and everything in there
and if they don't have everything in
there they don't function but they
really focus on fashion and commerce and
and fast-moving infrastructure and this
rapid turnover of material and so that
not only do they learn fast because of
that approach to things they may be a
little more brittle in some ways they
may go down with an economic downturn
like we're talking about Detroit but in
a sense the relationship they bear to
the whole and is not only do they learn
for themselves they teach everybody else
cities are always teaching the
civilizations they're in how to be
civilized or what civilization is about
and so I think it is the case that
cities do in fact adapt faster learn
faster and thereby have something to
teach everybody who wants to pay
attention to what cities are up to we've
had about 13 different variations of
this question from Daniel what is the
correlation between food production and
urban growth who is growing the food
food production and urban growth
if the village is empty out will anybody
stick around to grow farm part of what's
going on look it's not all the villages
are just boring and hard-working
in many cases there's real environmental
degradation in the rural countryside and
it makes it that much harder for a
person to get by even in subsistence
mode they're places like Rwanda but
another thing is going on is a vastly
more efficient agriculture where it's
much less labor-intensive you convey
against agribusiness and and genetically
modified crops and so on but in fact
these things grow a lot more food with
much less need for people doing every
damn thing there's less stupid
and so the stupa laborers are coming to
town because they're running out of jobs
it's part of the story but they're not
starving in town they were starving in
the countryside in many cases this is
part of what brings them to the city one
of the things that happens in the cities
in terms of governments is you have a
whole lot of voters in one place who can
gather and come downtown and say that
we're hungry or we need this or we need
that that doesn't happen in the
countryside so one of the things that
shitty cities ensure and we saw this all
the way back in Roman history is bread
and circuses there will be food and
there will be entertainment
from Eugene does the internet its
connectedness mitigate the forces
driving people to cities we keep waiting
for that knowing everybody's going to
telecommute over there super broadband
link to uh satellite or something now
what will it take i don't know i
telecommute all the way from Sausalito
you know I almost became a firefighter
and went to Idaho to study get a PhD in
firefighting and I would be living in
Moscow I know and I wouldn't have the
faintest idea what yeah I would have the
internet by now and there'd be a
Starbucks in town and I'd be able to get
you know Boutique lettuce and stuff like
that but it's 30 years later than
everybody else so we're still waiting
maybe Neil Gershenfeld in the guys who
can really manage remote manufacture
desktop whole factories nanotech or
something like that where you can get
the stuff
but you know how it's so far the
Internet is making more the world feel
like they're in a city and less of the
city folks feel like they ought to be in
the country this one is from Jessica
Richmond there you are I'm gonna
paraphrase a little bit if does this
it's a city state going to become the
ultimate unit of government if you have
a collapsing power of the nation-state
and you have rising cities does that
mean that city state will become the new
unit I think this would be a useful
research to do right now his city states
that happening thing I had the good
fortune of being going to Singapore a
couple of weeks ago working with the
Singapore government and years ago I
studied Venice like mad because Venice
really interests me for 800 years they
ran a mercantile Empire and they danced
on the razor's edge of history better
than any other entity of their size in
Europe and they managed everybody and
that's the way Singapore is behaving
these days this is a country totally
without natural resources so it treats
its people as the main natural resource
and has grown them and is a extremely
not a cool place to be but it's a place
where various developing nation city
planners and so on they all traipse to
Singapore see how do you do it so
they're going basically to a city-state
there I think that that as Venice was a
success and Rome was a success in Athens
and Sparta with those city-state
successes if the nation's keep being
blended back in instead of being the
major event that you'll see cities being
more and more the players that call the
tunes
and that the nations are treated as
regions around cities and and run that
way but you know that's a prediction we
can see if it plays out or not right now
city states are on the rise as such